now that Disney pluses mandalorian has
introduced a mysterious new character
that bears more than a passing
resemblance to the Jedi Master Yoda it
got us thinking what's up with this
species of pint-sized 20 eared aliens
what makes them so special and what have
we learned about them over the years in
a movie phone interview between George
Lucas and Hayden Christensen were they
answered fan questions
Lucas was asked about Yoda species and
his off-screen history Lucas described
Yoda as the magical character he has no
background he comes and he goes he's the
subversive secret mysterious stranger as
the years went on in the expanded
universe was created Lucas still didn't
want anyone to give Yoda any kind of
backstory he eventually added another
character of Yoda species to the Phantom
Menace or on her in a bit and let
creators in the expanded universe invent
a couple more of the same species but
when Lucas sold Star Wars to Disney
everything in the expanded universe was
considered non canon leaving only three
Yoda like characters in the Star Wars
universe while there have been several
of Yoda species including those from the
extended universe and the Knights of the
Old Republic video game at this point in
time there are only three in the
official Star Wars Canon Yoda gadelle
and this new child character
colloquially known to fans as baby Yoda
Yoda of course is the most visible of
his species appearing in six films as
well as in the animated shows Star Wars
rebels and Star Wars the Clone Wars
last time I couldn't see you
growing your abilities our gadelle a
female of the Yoda species was seen in
the Phantom Menace she was a Jedi Master
and a member of the Jedi High Council
alongside Yoda saddle was there when
qui-gon jinn brought a young Anakin
Skywalker to be evaluated by the Jedi
High Council however after the Battle of
Naboo gadelle wanted a break from the
Jedi Council and she was already gone
when the Clone Wars began to air as the
child has only recently been introduced
to us in the Mandalorian there is very
little information known about it we
know it's approximately fifty years old
and that it's strong with the force we
also know it tried to help the Bounty
Hunter heal his wounds the only other
thing we know about baby Yoda right now
is that it has captured our hearts and
it must be protected at all costs
according to Star Wars calm the force is
quote a mysterious energy field created
by life that binds the Galaxy together
the Jedi the Sith and other force
sensitive beings harness the power of
the force giving them amazing abilities
such as levitating objects tricking
minds and seeing things before they
happen and as you probably guessed the
yoda species is strong with the force
Yoda is seen using it several times
throughout the Star Wars franchise the
first time we see him use it is in the
Empire Strikes Back when training Luke
after Skywalker fails to lift his x-wing
out of the bottom of the swamp
Yoda shows him that it is indeed
possible to use the Force to lift
something so heavy we were also blessed
to see baby Yoda used the force in the
second episode of the Mandalorian in the
scene the bounty hunter is being
attacked by a giant alien after stealing
an egg from the creatures cave just when
it looks like he's done for baby Yoda
reaches out and lifts the monster into
the air allowing the Bounty Hunter to
grab his knife and kill it lifting that
monster took everything out of baby Yoda
though and he went night-night for a
long while afterwards in the mandalorian
when the title hero and IG 11 realized
the target they're looking for is
actually baby Yoda the bounty hunter
says quotes wait they said 50 years old
IG 11 then tells him quote species aged
differently perhaps it could live many
centuries
so if baby Yoda is 50 years old that
would please him be
born around the same time as Anakin
Skywalker after all the Mandalorian
takes place five years after Return of
the Jedi the film in which he Oded eyes
we know that Yoda was approximately 900
years old at the time of his death
around the age of 100 Yoda had already
become a Jedi Master and had begun
training apprentices when he died it was
thought they goda had taught over 20,000
Jedi including Count Dooku and of course
Luke Skywalker there still is a bit of
mystery when it comes to just how long
Yoda species lives because both Yoda and
nate'll who in the non-canon expanded
universe was 483 years old at the time
of her death were Jedi and it's thought
they could live longer than an average
member of the species in case there was
any doubt baby Yoda made it perfectly
clear in Episode two of the Mandalorian
but his species definitely eats meat he
catches a rather large frog like
creature and swallows it whole although
we don't really see Yoda eating during
any of his appearances well other than
stealing a bite of Luke's dinner it was
thought his species we're carnivores due
to the shape of their teeth hey dinner
Yodas chompers are super sharp like
razors which can make quick work of
ripping and chewing the skin of an
animal those large claws on the end of
their three fingers also come into play
making it easy to stab their potential
meal we know Yoda was eating vegetables
while living on Dagobah though on the
day Luke came to the swamp planet the
tiny alien was making something called
root leaf stew made of yarrow Mangala
seeds with some mushroom spores tossed
in for good measure this was part of
Yoda's diet while exiled whether all of
the Yoda species also eat vegetables
isn't known but this makes Yoda himself
an omnivore check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]